[Applause]  start by making the intense jerk  marinade first scotch bonnet chilies  they may be small but had real heat and  a fruity punch  then chopped garlic and fresh thyme  [Music]  for spice add ground cloves cinnamon  nutmeg and allspice  season with salt and pepper and combined  with olive oil  [Music]  next score chicken legs so the hot spicy  flavors get deep inside the meat  rub thoroughly with the jug mix and  marinade  [Applause]  and olive oil to a hot dish Brown the  marinated chicken for 10 minutes  then add Worcestershire sauce  [Music]  cover and cook in the oven at 220  degrees for 20 minutes  [Music]  hot spicy jerk chicken easy to make and  finger licking good  next fried corn-on-the-cob  in olive oil white bait our annoyingly  fish our healthy delicious and cooking  minutes  [Music]